[Music]
my name is Isabelle Oscar Bono and I've
been playing since I was eight years old
I'm playing for a team Mamba my coaches
Kobe Bryant it's inspiring to be coached
by one of the goats teaching us a lot of
stuff I'm really grateful
I play Horus like at the end of my
workout just to fool around have a lot
of tricks so it's gonna be like pop out
hi I'm Megan and I think I'm the
beginner in this video oh my god I think
the fact that horse is more skill and
technique based than like athletic will
play to my advantage because I just have
to stand there and do one thing as
opposed to running and doing multiple
things my grandpa once played for the
Celtics a long time ago so that's in my
blood
ball is life hi I'm Jeff Williams in
college I played a little bit I was part
of frat league and now just playing at
LA Fitness once every like a couple
weeks the technical aspect is kind of
disadvantage I'm more of like the
athletic type but you know we're here I
play basketball we're gonna make it work
hey my name is Zach and I kinda play
basketball very casually I'm a huge
basketball fan and I play NBA 2k a lot
so maybe that'll help me today maybe not
probably not I'm terrified of Izzie
she's so good and I feel like she's just
gonna go a little like easy and then
just take it to another level and we're
all just gonna lose the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna do a left
hand close so this one should be easy
like that oh you are hope my left hand
is illiterate I want to do it so bad I
think we all were like that's easy and
then we're all right-handed that's an H
for everybody okay the next one is still
left hand but you're doing on the right
side oh wait you got to go again it's
like that she's immediately doing what
she knows will destroy us let's go baby
[Music]
I can't use my left hand I'm just
realizing this okay that's why they just
saw us short like great oh thank you at
what point do we take control of the
ball she has to miss she has to miss so
never grandpa I feel your spirit in my
hands okay we did not have to disrespect
grandpa boy cough like that oh my gosh
grandpa boy cough no this land we're
gonna do it's kind of like this it's
plunger wolf yeah she's at the point
where she's cheering us on
she just clapped for you you're that bad
so now we're gonna do like this one so
it's gonna be like that was not it was
it it if I do this that's enough I'm out
we're gonna go inside
[Music]
nice throw it out I'm out
it's like if someone's gonna block your
shop right here to do a draw change
cross the train look and make it but
when it but one hand now we're gonna do
the same thing on the left hand we cross
over ten and a left-handers yeah
sick so you're gonna throw it out yank
it right hand can you miss the layup so
I could do something see we got here
[Music]
what was that I saw the destructor
grandpa blood Kostas washing over you
right now so we're gonna do like a Isiah
Thomas Oh OOP that person Oh got him
this nope did not and you still have no
letters no Heights it
[Applause]
so here's our new rules that we have to
make because you're so good it's the
same thing but now you're going to do
your shot and then after that it
switches to the next person it looks so
easy when you're not doing it finally I
get to create my own shot so I'm about
to be real creative with it and just hit
up a regular free-throw I'm gonna do a
free throw but first I was the best miss
we've had all day I'm going to do
nothing crazy just a normal shot and
then you hit rim and he rebounds and
then you go okay so that's you don't
have to do it now we're back at your
shop that's heavy
ah devastation round two let's do it
[Applause]
just follow through
[Music]
mmm okay did it look as good with Oh
looking at where it was then we're back
to you it out wraparound see once it
comes with back to the right I'm good
with the right I got this yes we're
gonna do a simple we're gonna do it
right hand II can't I just do it in that
look wait you got to do it oh my hero
we're gonna attempt on your knees we've
been blessed come oh my goodness you
just gotta give it a little arc thank
you for coming to my class
oh my god so quickly I remember the line
oh no I don't know what I'm gonna do
good
all right sick sick sick bank shot
oh I needed that one oh my god I don't
know what I'm gonna do do it all right I
bet this I mean you're supposed to but
the thing is I just say that for later
now watch and be amazed I think I'm
gonna bring it back we were doing well
over here and but see that's why we
don't do our left sides because things
like that happen
we're gonna go eyes closed please
everyone please close your eyes
Oh three three spit between between
between between thank you she just goes
for it shouldn't even hesitate Oh no
hesitation for me either
I'm out
you did great welcome to the losers
circle so we're gonna go blow by blow by
left are we blowing by
I'll stand there no there's no yeah no
it's over
two out of three there you don't even
have to do the third one it was really
fun yeah you guys have a lot of practice
to do with your left hand with your
reverses yeah all right
[Music]